le couple dont on parle le plus mine de
rien c'est quand même présidentielle ce
que y'a plein de couple voilà je vous
prendre efficient nathalie aussi qu avec
et nathalie elle est très bien pour son
âge
qui sait vivian nathalie ah oui mais ça
c'est des gens veulent pas quoi merci on
n'a pas les mêmes de référence ne sait
pas quand emmanuel macron est devenu
président il ya des vannes les 24 ans
qui sépare de sa femme brigitte ont
beaucoup choqué vous savez lors d'une
conférence de presse le président était
revenue sur les rumeurs d'homosexualité
à son égard depuis avait évoqué le sujet
de la différence d'âge avec sa femme qui
soulevait de nombreuses remarques
sexistes et vous allez donner votre avis
non sinon je vais finir expulsés mois
sans jamais donner votre avis quand même
regarder on disait dans les dîners
parisiens que j'étais homosexuel que je
vivais entre autres avec mathieu gallet
m'enfin on a peut-être été d'autres
notre vie parallèle c'est assez
déplaisante quand ce n'est pas le cas
c'est dit trois choses 1 une dégradation
profonde des moeurs politiques
deuxième chose c'est que ça en dit long
sur l'homophobie rampante et la
troisième c'est que ça en dit beaucoup
sur la misogynie rampant exactement
parce que si j'avais eu 20 ans de plus
que mon épouse personne n'aurait pensé
une seule seconde que je pouvais être un
couple illégitime c'est parce qu'elle a
vingt ans de plus que moi que beaucoup
disaient ce truc les pattes au namm
c'est pas possible
donc en fait c'est tu dis simplement que
ces gens là ont un grand problème avec
les représentations sociales et la place
de la femme
alors vous avez vu en quoi alors sur le
mandat ce qui a je comprends plus en
pleine voie lors la com com com comme
quoi vous comprenez pas là ce qu'il
comprend pas il dit qu'en fait il avait
été le contraire exact ou alors si mais
je dis est ce que tu es choqué
franchement oui un petit peu quand ils
sont arrivés en 2010 cette main dans la
main et ça m'a choqué vous avez dit quoi
ben ouais ça vous à ça vous a plu
ben je me suis jeune va pas tarder à
partir sa vie en séries tu veux finir
expulsés mois après quel âge ma maman
elle a 43 ans d'accord et voir bien plus
vote soit pas mon papa il a 44 ans
maintenant mais il est décédé
d'accord mais non mais non ils avaient
un angle différent arrivé à pas de
talent mais alors non mais ne pouvait
pas dire c'est maintenant aujourd'hui il
ya des gens aujourd'hui en plus y'a un
truc qui se passe c'est que les gens de
60 ans de 50 ans de 70 ans sont plus du
tout les mêmes en fer qui a acquis à 30
ans c'est vrai que ça n'a rien à voir je
pense que maintenant il ya une
différence en fait de 10
vous enlevez disant à chaque en plus moi
quand je prends par exemple dit brigitte
mac où elle a quel âge 75 mais non 65
ans à la comme vous alors à la 70e
choisir je préfère être comme vous le
dire